netflix is doing a thing on uh hulk
hogan chris hemsworth is playing hulk
hogan
what i'm gonna tell you man i'm gonna
it's gonna like peel back the the kind
of the were you a hulkster guy
i was macho man me too when i get hurt
as a kid
instead of crying i'd go macho man
that's how big of a fan i was yeah i
fell on my bike and i'd be like macho
man
watching the tears
[Music]
yeah but chris hemsworth just put on
massive weight to play hulk hogan
i loved macho man i loved miss
elizabeth i was a warrior fan too
ultimate warrior he just
not the time you know people were like
oh he's gay it's like
at the time i was like no now i'm older
i'm like oh my god do you think so
to me he just seen the warriors like out
really i think he passed away but he did
pass away was he out
yeah like what gave it away dude the
rainbow bands and the [ __ ] teased
hair all the time
but that's half of the wwe man he was
really into it
i the thing is what always struck me as
him and and
by the way i loved watching them but on
the mic he seemed like
the dummiest dummy like when you would
hear him talk and i know that was
part of the character yeah tone it down
a notch on the dumbass
the pro my my favorite promo guy of all
time
is jake the snake jake the snake because
he had that real
easy way of talking oh he was good it's
scary
i like the undertaker too and i also my
favorite
promo rip of all time is when booker t
washington drops the end ball
m-bomb and saint hulk hogan no and
everybody
hulk hogan coming for you and says the
n-word on accident he goes up and then
the girl goes oh
i never see that yeah you can tell he's
just dropping the handbomb like yeah
and you see the girl in the back like
this
it's great bring that up chin it's
fantastic you never see that what's his
name against
that booker booker two people washington
i think might be booker t
dude it's probably one of the first
promos that come up
randy the macho man and i i
steroids to me right you always knew he
did steroids
but when he you remember him in
spider-man ran to the mountain
he looked oh dude he was so juicy oh
like he died like three weeks after that
dude he was he was he had veins in his
nose
like he was all get down from here
and you're like are you okay dude i was
like like the lines were tough to get
out
he was like oh yeah and he's not get
down from here
y'all oh he's gonna have a heart attack
he's all purple
dude i'm here to turn this up oh no
watch the girl
well i'll never mind this real quick
like you're normal
look at the white girl i can't believe
you guys are seeing this like so excited
he's talking about a click the only
click you need to know about
the harlem heath and the sharing see
because what you're dealing with here
look at her brotherhood it's never
stopped from this point on
wcw we take what we want and after we
take lex luga in the child
we want the gold sucker hulk hogan we
got it for you
[ __ ]
did you say did you see him go oh
and
[Applause]
no the dude's dating character was dude
who over here man
because he knows that he's like oh [ __ ]
yeah he's a guy over there like
the guy you're the guy in the left
the guy on the left was like i guess we
know who's doing the promo next week
like that dude
oh my god it mean jane that
roll me and jean was like dude anyways
isn't that great i i will the one thing
that always struck me when i was
watching wrestling
is you know is like they got to wear
those tiny
shorts yeah but they're so juiced up ooh
they're juicy
they're i love it like yeah i'm in it
but like i think if you were gonna make
me wear something that tight
i would have to i couldn't go tiny dick
like that no
but but they uh they definitely do some
stuff i would have to i would have to
put like a like like um
like a like a fleshlight but a
fleshlight a permanent fleshlight that
is just
you put it on to make your dick look
bigger that's fair that's actually not a
terrible product
no or even like a thick gummy worm yeah
yeah something like that sick
earthworm yeah dude and you just it's
like a dick call it a dick sock
and it just makes your dick look not a
bad idea this is not a terrible idea you
say for wrestlers like you're not
wearing it tomorrow yeah you're like
wait what
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son